На Кліматичному форумі СОР26 в Глазго представники близько 200 країн світу зібралися,
аби узгодити спільну політику боротьби з глобальним потеплінням.
Свій оновлений Національно визначений внесок (НВВ) презентувала й  Україна.
Документ ставить за мету до 2030 року скоротити викиди парникових газів до рівня 35% порівняно з 1990 роком.
Наскільки  амбітні такі кліматичні цілі та як саме Україна планує їх досягати?
За планом Міндовкілля, до 2030 року викиди від транспорту мають знизитися до 36% у порівнянні з 1990-им роком.
Такої мети планують досягти, зокрема, підвищенням сертифікаційних вимог для нових авто,
стимулюючи попит на електротранспорт, а також розвитком муніципального транспорту.
Водночас масштабний перехід на більш екологічний транспорт може бути під загрозою, зокрема,
якщо в Україні продовжуватиметься тенденція на скуповування вже потриманих автівок з-за кордону.
Кількість авто продовжуватиме зростати, і ви знаєте, що ЄС і США прийняли рішення
щодо заборони продажу авто з двигунами внутрішнього згоряння з 30-го, 35-го якогось там іншого року.
Це означає, що євробляхи чи янкибляхи, куди вони підуть?
Вони, в першу чергу, підуть в Україну, тому що у нас в порівнянні з європейцями чи американцями дуже низький рівень доходів.
Наразі система оподаткування викидів СО2 в Україні, на думку експертів, працює досить неефективно.
По-перше, податок на викиди СО2 - один з найнижчих у Європі: 10 гривень (приблизно 33 євроценти) за тонну викидів СО2.
Тоді як у європейських країнах цей податок сягає від 20 до 108 євро.
Незначна сума в Україні не стимулює українські компанії, які викидають найбільше вуглецю, скорочувати свої викиди і модернізувати виробництво.
До механізму використання все ж отриманих державою податків на викиди також є питання.
Так, наприклад, з 2019 року держбюджет отримав таким чином понад 900 млн грн.
Проте експерти вказують, що ці гроші були спрямовані до загального фонду державного бюджету, без цільового використання.
А отже, податок на викиди СО2 жодним чином не сприяє покращенню екологічної ситуації в країні.
У нас досить низькі податки, і ці гроші можна було би спрямувати на якісь заходи, які забезпечили скорочення парникових газів.
Є ініціативи в ЄС, Німеччині, де частково промисловості гроші давалися на якусь модернізацію, якщо вона досить дорога.
Але важливо не повністю повертати гроші промисловості, і неважливо, як саме вони ці гроші будуть використовувати,
а моніторити, проводити дослідження, обирати саме ті напрямки, які дійсно будуть вести до скорочення.
Тому у планах, по-перше, підвищити податок з 10 гривень до 30 гривень за тонну.
Хоча деякі експерти вважають, що це все ще незначна сумма.
А по-друге, створити кліматичний фонд, який спрямовуватиме кошти в технології по скороченню викидів парникових газів.
Українські ТЕС - одні з найбільших забруднювачів повітря у Європі.
Вони не модернізувалися десятиріччями, що зумовлює ще більшу кількість викидів.
План Міністерства довкілля передбачає модернізацію об’єктів теплопостачання, що сприятиме зменшенню
викидів ТЕС з 16 млн тонн CO2-еквіваленту у 2018 році до 13 млн тонн CO2-еквіваленту у 2030 році.
Під час форуму у Глазго Україна приєдналася до коаліції Powering Past Coal Alliance,
яка передбачає відмову від вугільної генерації та перехід на відновлювані джерела енергії.
Дедлайн, який Україна встановила для державних електростанцій – 2035 рік.
Водночас, досі під питанням, як влада втілюватиме таке рішення.
Відмовитися від теплової генерації загалом неможливо, оскільки тільки вона може перекрити пікові навантаження попиту на електроенергію.
Однак це не обов'язково має бути вуггіля.
Його можна замінити або на газ, що не є варіантом з огляду на газову залежність України від Росії,
або на біопаливо, що вимагає складної технології для масштабного впровадження.
У червні 2021 року Володимир Зеленський ініціював екологічний проєкт "Зелена країна", мета якого – збільшити площу лісів в Україні.
А на форумі у Глазго Україна приєдналась до декларації, першим пунктом якої є збереження лісів та інших екосистем.
І попри те, що курс на висадку і збереження лісів є позитивним, виконання плану може проходити не так безхмарно.
У цілому, висадка дерев - це добре, але важливо правильно підходити з кооперацією з науковцями.
Наприклад, на рівні міністерства вони дійсно залучили науковців, зробили робочу групу і т.д.,
але коли ця активність спустилася до лісгоспів, то там почався хаос, висадка цих дерев може проводитися не в тих місцях,
де це потрібно, або висадка дерев, які просто не зможуть там в умовах, які у нас зараз змінюються, вони просто там загинуть у найближчі роки.
Тож уся ця активність не матиме ефекту, який передбачався.
Те, що Україна почала впроваджувати екологічні ініціативи і звертати дедалі більше уваги на декарбонізацію, безумовно, позитивний процес.
Однак і у експертів, і у представників бізнесу виникають питання, як держава
балансуватиме між зростанням економіки і зменшенням викидів парникових газів.
Утім, навіть якщо до 2030 року Україні вдасться виконати весь план, представлений у НВВ,
це буде всього лише 7%, починаючи з 2019 року, до кліматичної нейтральності у 2060 році.
Тобто за 10 років буде скорочено викиди парникових газів на 7%, а потім за наступні 30 років теоретично треба скоротити 93%.
А це вимагатиме докорінних змін у більшості критичних сфер.